ولا يمكن لنا ان نمر ونعبر عن الاردن بدون
ان نسلم على سوها جميل من هناك مراسله
صباح العربيه سهى انت علم من اعلام الاردن
الاعلامي في التقارير وفي الظهور وفي
الافكار التي اتحفتينا بها طوال لهذا
العام الكلمه لكي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام بدايه
شكرا نادين على هذا الكلام على الصعيد
الشخصي بدايه اردنيه في يوم من الايام في
هذا العام الذي سيمضي التقيت بك نادين كان
من اجمل الايام صراحه وبكل الامانه هذه
الشخصيه نادين خماش اتمنى الجميع ان يعرف
نادين على حقيقتها الجميله هذا بالنسبه لي
كانت من اجمل الايام اما بالنسبه
للاردنيين اجمالا نرد على الاردنيين او
يودع الاردنيون هذا العام بين الحزن
والفرح بين الماساه وبين الامل ايه كان
هناك انهيار لعماره في منطقه الويبده ولكن
اخراج الطفله ملاك من تحت الانقاذ بعد
يومين كان خبرا سرا لجميع الاردنيين الذين
انتظروا هذا الخبر في ظل الظروف الصعبه
التي يمر بها همم كان هناك خبر ايضا ادراج
المنسف كاكله تاريخيه واكله شعبيه وهويه
اردنيه على قائمه التراث العالمي اليونسكو
هذا يعزز طبعا هذا الطبق عالميا خاصه وان
الاردنيون افتخرون فيه به جميع الولائم
والعزائم وهو هويه تعرف عنهم اضافه الى
اختيار الاردن همم الدوله الاكثر رومانسيه
للسياحه همم في الشرق الاوسط لعام 2022
وهذا بالنسبه للاردنيين طبعا خبر جميل جدا
على الصعيد السياحي خاصه وانه رافد مهم
للاقتصاد وغيرها من الاخبار السعيده التي
مرت ولكن للاسف كانت الاخبار المتتاليه
مؤخرا منها الاعتصامات على ارتفاع اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه وما حدث مع اشتباك من
رجال الامن وخساره اربعه منهم ودعنا هذا
العام بهذه الاخبار السيئه ولكن كل ما
يتمناه الاردنيون هو عكس ما حدث معهم في
عام
2-22 ان يحدث هناك يعني
الاخبار يملؤها الامل همم الانتعاش
الاقتصادي الانعاش السياحي والانتعاش على
الصعيد الشخصي
اكيد وهذا ما نتمناه بكل الصعده لجميع
الدول ولنك افراد ايضا شكرا سهى جميل
مراسله صباح العربيه من عمان
[موسيقى]
كمان
نصف ونصف واحنا بنطبح ان شاء الله السنه
الجديده يكون افضل
كثير كثير
كثير ممتعه وكنا بالمدرسه كثير مبسوطين
كان في اجواء رائعه فيها وكتير كيفنا
[موسيقى]
كثير ممتازه من ناحيه مهنيه الحمد لله
الايرادات كل شيء تمام الشغل زاد عندك
والله من ناحيه المهنيه الحمد لله كويسه
حسب
مجال كدوله اردنيه هون عندك الحياه
المهنيه مشكله طبعا في ناس مرتاحه وناس مش
مرتاحه
[موسيقى]